DANNY: Now, dude, if
that Chevy right there--
SHANNON: Two-door.
--if it was a two-door,
I'd be all over it.
And I know there's this mystique
that Danny hates four-doors.
That's not true.
There are four-doors
that I absolutely love.
But from my personal taste,
if that car was a two-door,
we'd be knocking on the door.
Don't look.
Don't look at the
Volkswagen, Shannon.
I know it's difficult for you to
pass up any kind of a bug, man.
- What's that, like, a '69?
- See?
We're going to set
up an intervention.
What's that right there?
We got something.
We got a '67 Camaro.
Now, that's a full
on convertible.
Let's at least take a look, man.
Yes, it looks very confused.
SHANNON: It's been sitting
like this for a long time.
DANNY: Yeah.
SHANNON: Something about
that race seat in there.
DANNY: No.
I would go back to
original buckets.
Let's see what the
story is on this.
I stopped to talk to
you about your Camaro.
What's your name, brother?
Stewart, I'm Danny.
It's very nice to meet you.
This is Shannon.
- Nice to meet you, Stewart.
'67?
Yes, right?
DANNY: This is awesome, bro.
Chevy debuted their 1967 Camaro
to compete with Ford's Mustang.
No easy task, but the Camaro
was up to the challenge.
It had the looks,
handling, and speed
every gearhead was looking for.
The Camaro would come to beat
the Mustang in sales in 1977,
and remain a major player in
the performance car market
all the way up until 2002.
With sales numbers tailing off,
Chevy decided to pull the plug
on their iconic Camaro.
The mighty Camaro
returned in 2010
with first-generation
styling and modern features
like independent
four-wheel suspension.
Chevy hoped to
capture the old school
muscle car crowd and a whole
new generation car enthusiast
as well.
You've had this
car for how long?
Since '79.
SHANNON: How did
you get this baby?
Well, my high
school girlfriend
in '67 had a yellow '67 Camaro.
So what do you think
I'm looking for?
So I'm looking for a '67 Camaro,
and I found it the junkyard.
What's the engine in it?
Right now, it's got a 350.
And it's got roller
can, roller lifters.
So that's a rocket sled.
Yeah, I see the
race seats in it.
Actually, I'm going to
go back to the originals.
You called it.
Is that the factory seat
sitting on the ground?
STEWART: Yeah.
DANNY: Nice.
So you've got a
car guy for years?
Well, yeah.
But you guys probably know why.
I can repair these.
I did the water pump, fuel
pump, and an alternator,
and a couple of hoses.
I spent $150.
- Right.
How long has she
been off the road?
How long you been
working on her?
It's been 15 years.
15 years.
How much would
you sell this for?
$50,000.
OK, so it's your baby.
This car is not for sale.
Yeah, no.
You'd have to be insane.